foreign
for a frightening situation at Hulen
Mall in Fort Worth is a convicted sex
criminal and registered sex offender
Fort Worth Police say he was trying to
record a woman in the restroom before
pulling out what Shoppers thought was a
gun what was it what did he pull out
if it wasn't a gun
Fox 4's Macy Jenkins George is now live
from Fort Worth with the story Macy
hi hi hi
Susan I'm like three different races
mushed together
yeah she looks like a [ __ ] somebody
from the future she really does remember
the [ __ ] South Park episode The Goo
bags yeah this is a goo bag Heather well
the good news is that no one was injured
in all of this commotion but police do
say that the man attempting to illegally
record a woman in the bathroom was
dressed up like a woman himself well
wait a second hold on
I was assured that that was not going to
happen and that was not going to be a
problem
I was told
incredibly by trans activists half of
them were dead that
I was told that this would be something
that wouldn't be occurring half of the
left which are dead yes
so I feel like I want an apology okay
well you're not getting it from half of
them that's for sure
twice as hard
yeah because that's what they're known
for apologizing yeah Panic around 4 30
p.m on Christmas Eve after police say a
woman claims okay on the John said was
it Opie since it was filming somebody in
the bathroom
good reference very funny
yes the woman who was rolling in a wig
names someone threatened to shoot her
Tina James says she got attacked around
the same time from her daughter who
works at the mall saying someone inside
had a gun as a parent you got to
understand how disturbing that was for
me as a mother of four or we're worried
about our children's safety every time
they leave the house I bet you I bet you
she celebrates Kwanzaa
she seemed like the same the same one
that would be doing the Cha-Cha Slide
she celebrates Kwanzaa for sure
it's a Kwanza loving woman every time
they leave the house Fort Worth Police
say after speaking with the victim they
learned the confrontation started in the
women's restroom well she was using the
restroom it's not me shut up she
observed what she believed to be a cell
phone coming from underneath the stall
Corporal Joshua Johnson says the woman
quickly left the stall and started
chasing after a man later identified as
45 year old Douglas Egan who the victim
says was dressed like a woman police say
the victim followed Egan all the way
outside that's when another witness saw
what was happening and stepped in at
that point the suspect pulled out and
presented what appeared to be a gun he
pulled it from a backpack which he was
carrying and pointed out at the first
witness and then continued to flee from
that Point Police say apparently was a
pepper ball gun like one of those guns
that shoots the yeah yeah more and more
witnesses started to gather and from a
distance watched Egan change out of
women's clothing and into men's clothing
huh well you know why I know why why did
each why would he why would he why would
he change out of clothing because
obviously
it was a heist
oh God yeah this time we're hitting hole
in Mall let's do it okay so here's what
you're gonna do you're gonna wear a
dress okay you're gonna video One let's
just hear me out this let me finish
you're gonna wear a dress
and you're gonna go to the female
bathroom and you're gonna film people
okay and then hold this gun this pepper
gun this realistic gun looks like a
regular gun I want you to hold it I want
you to aim it at the police okay all
right hear me out on this yeah wouldn't
it make more sense if I posed as the
manager of the Cinnabon and we have
Frozen going as the woman okay Frozen
that's more possible his people are more
Frozen you're gonna be because Blair
white blame her you're gonna dress like
a woman that's not a good reason it's
good for good enough for this bit you're
gonna put a wig on you're gonna go into
the bathroom and you're going to film
people using the bathroom you're gonna
take this realistic looking gun and
you're gonna aim it at the police okay
in the meantime I'm gonna be poisoning
all the Cinnabons so I can cause a
diversion for you to escape you're not
killing people though right he's just
getting him sick
Mercer not killing people you're just
getting them sick right do we want to
get frozen out of there or not okay look
whatever fine that's fine so anyway when
the [ __ ] parking lot's all jammed up
with ambulances trying to get all these
dead people out of the food court Frozen
you get out the back okay I'm gonna
steal a police uniform and I'm gonna
pretend that I'm this police officer
okay I'm gonna feed a false story in
there well pessie what's your job I
forgot all right now I'm gonna leave I
got a Gatorade because I'm gonna be
making Todd's wife come a lot this isn't
about you [ __ ] I keep telling you
that this is not what this is about okay
forget it hey Virgie what you're gonna
do is you're gonna go into the PacSun
and steal a bunch of clothes while we're
all doing that okay just because you
need you need clothes yeah honestly you
know what no I saw them in New York
you're gonna go into the Burlington Coat
Factory and get yourself something warm
that way I'm not walking around with
nothing fur line with the [ __ ] newsie
in New York faux fur
foreign